en france 24 es momento de hablar de
economía por ello me acompaña en el
estudio mi compañera daniela blandón
daniela bienvenida el tema de esta
crónica son las elecciones en nicaragua
vamos a hablar en que cuéntanos usted en
qué estado económico llega a este país
centroamericano a las polémicas
elecciones o la valentina pues
recordemos que el presidente de
nicaragua daniel ortega está buscando la
reelección en los comicios de este
domingo 7 de noviembre para ejercer su
quinto mandato y un puñado de
contrincantes quiere darle la batalla
pero gobernar nicaragua está lleno de
complejidades no sólo desde el punto de
vista político sino también económico
veamos las cifras valentina la economía
se ha debilitado desde la crisis
política que inició en 2018 entre 2000 y
2017 es el producto interno bruto había
crecido en promedio 39 % anual impulsado
principalmente por las remesas y por la
inversión extranjera directa pero
después de eso y hasta el 2020 el pib se
contrajo un 8 8% acumulados según el
banco mundial
hablamos como pudimos con dos analistas
para un poco más el tema pues hay
bastante dificultad en encontrar quién
hable en ese país debido a que están
penalizadas las declaraciones que acusan
al gobierno de fraude o de corrupción
entre otros y por eso muchos valentina
pues no quieren hablar manuel orozco
quien es experto en temas de
centroamérica nos dice desde washington
que retos le esperan a la economía
mire hay varios retos en primer lugar se
ve empresa a enfrentar con una comunidad
internacional que no va a reconocer al
gobierno entrante por ser parte de un
proceso ilegítimo de elecciones debido
al fraude y el encarcelamiento de todos
los candidatos presidenciales
entonces eso va a tener un efecto
inmediato sobre las relaciones
comerciales que tenga con varios países
en segundo lugar el efecto más
importante va a ser que en el 2022
nicaragua no va a poder endeudarse de la
10 manera que lo había venido haciendo
los últimos tres años porque su
capacidad de pago se está disminuyendo
pues es una situación bastante compleja
que podemos decir en torno al empleo
pues contrario a lo que muchos pudieran
imaginarse el desempleo en nicaragua no
sufrió grandes cambios con la pandemia y
se mantiene en un nivel relativamente
bajo la tasa de desocupación se ha
movido entre el 48 % y el 51 por ciento
a lo largo de la pandemia siendo los
hombres levemente más afectados que las
mujeres que también es algo inusual en
la región pero eso tiene una razón de
fondo y es que estas cifras tienen su
truquito valentina y es la amplia
informalidad como lo explica el
economista y analista político enrique
sáenz quien vive en el exilio en san
josé en costa rica de acuerdo con las
cifras oficiales el banco central
el 45 por ciento de estas son cifras al
mes de junio de este año el 45 por
ciento
de la fuerza laboral se encontraba en
condición de eso empleo que en nicaragua
se define como la población que trabaja
un día sí y un día no porque no
encuentra trabajo a tiempo completo y
las personas que ganan menos del salario
mínimo el 5 por ciento un poco más de
acuerdo con las cifras oficiales está en
desempleo abierto y el 13 por ciento en
una condición un poco particular que son
trabajadores sin remuneración esto suma
alrededor del 63 por ciento de la fuerza
laboral pues es que son varios factores
que confluyen en una situación bastante
preocupante pero entonces que se espera
para el futuro cercano pues valentina de
la economía nicaragüense como todas las
de la región se está ahí del mundo
también podríamos decir se está
recuperando de la pandemia y un punto
clave son las remesas son responsables
de casi una quinta parte del producto
interno bruto y es uno de los
porcentajes también más altos de américa
latina' todo por la migración hacia eeuu
pues este aumento en el número de
nicaragüenses que viven en el exterior
puede actuar como una válvula de escape
ante la crisis entre 2017 y 2020 las
transferencias de dinero desde el
exterior crecieron un 33 por ciento a
1850 millones de dólares daniela y que
se puede decir de indicadores económicos
en este país podemos destacar por
ejemplo cómo se ha comportado el dólar
en este país la depreciación que ha
subido la moneda nicaragüense que es el
córdoba cuando daniel ortega llegó al
poder un dólar costaba 18,03 córdobas
esto era en 2007 y hoy cuesta el doble
unos 35 aunque la moneda no es tan
volátil como otras de la región y le
terminó con un dato el salario mínimo de
ese país es de 6 mil 500 córdobas o sea
un poco más de 180 dólares daniela
muchas gracias por esta ampliación a
ustedes por su sintonía continúen con
nosotros que hay más en france 24
[Música]